tati pessoal com bom eu vim falar um
pouquinho pra vocês sobre essa minha
jornada empreendedora o quanto eu tive
que me adaptar e aprender a superar para
conseguir ter hoje uma carreira de
empreendedorismo dentro do startup
dentro de vários outros eventos e coisas
que eu faço chegar até aqui hoje
a primeira coisa que eu queria dizer pra
vocês é que eu sou uma pessoa que eu
tenho medo de falar em público
medo não tenho pânico avô de falar em
corpo a primeira vez que eu subi no
palco eu tive um blecaute
eu não conseguia ver nada eu não
conseguia falar eu não conseguia
respirar
eu não sabia se ia desmaiar ou se eu ia
chorar
então se eu caí aqui vocês já sabem que
a pessoa que se respirava mas maior do
que a minha o meu medo o medo de falar
em público é o maior medo do ser humano
maior até do que a morte sempre foi a
minha vontade de enfrentar desafios
sempre foi a minha vontade de mudar a
minha própria opinião do que não era
possível e vontade de vencer o desafio é
uma característica primária para ser
empreendedor
todos os empreendedores são por natureza
inquietos
eles podem até estar dentro de uma
empresa trabalhar com carreiras
convencionais mas ele nunca está
satisfeito
ele sempre está procurando um jeito de
fazer melhor e fazer diferente de fazer
alguma coisa que deixa uma marca é
empreendedor é realmente um desafio
emocional
a pessoa tem que ter paixão tem que ter
vontade tem que ter disposição mas a
pessoa precisa ter motivação
a minha maior motivação para fazer o que
eu faço para ter começado a entender
minha maior realização são com certeza
as minhas filhas
sou mãe de gêmeos é a lara e ela isso e
eu comecei a empreender para ter mais
qualidade de vida para ter mais tempo
pra elas
eu achava que se eu tivesse mais tempo
eu conseguia aproveitar mais a a
maternidade
eu conseguiria é estar perto delas ser
um modelo para elas e ter uma história
na vida delas para elas contarem mas com
o tempo eu descobri que eu queria ser
mais do que simplesmente uma mãe dentro
de casa eu tinha uma carreira tenho uma
vida eu tinha sonhos eu tinha em
quitação e eu precisava realmente ter
uma forma de me realizar
profissionalmente então eu montei uma
startup que eu pudesse trabalhar em
qualquer lugar do mundo começar tap
digital pra poder conciliar as duas
coisas e o caminho do sucesso é mais ou
menos assim tudo culpa eu fui por um
caminho achei que era aquilo que eu
queria achei que a minha empresa da
forma como tinha montado os meus sonhos
a minha carreira
os meus objetivos estavam super definido
e aí eu encontrei várias paredes
fechadas vários caminhos tortos e eu
tive que mudar
eu tive que me adaptar e eu tive que
aceitar determinadas escolhas para
conseguir chegar ao meu objetivo e eu
descobri que simplesmente ser mãe e
deixar de lado a minha vida profissional
não seria suficiente não era realmente
aquilo que eu queria então quando a
gente às vezes tomo uma decisão num
momento da vida de fazer alguma coisa e
às vezes vira tudo de cabeça pra baixo
muda tudo achando que aquele é o caminho
certo
dificilmente a gente vai encontrar uma
linha reta até achar a saída até chegar
ao sucesso
então de informação eu sou formado em
direito que não tem nada a ver muito a
ver com o que eu faço hoje estou no
mercado digital
no meio do caminho eu fui adquirindo
outras habilidades
estudei muito e fiz um mba em marketing
e fiz mba em vendas fizeram pedir em
gestão de negócios não tem uma formação
acadêmica super bacana de coisas
completamente diferentes
eu fundei algumas empresas tive algumas
empresas no mercado tradicional
tive uma carreira no mercado corporativo
de mais de dez anos trabalha
a multinacional e eu achava que eu sabia
bastante coisa
belo currículo na época quando o papel e
que eu estava pronta realmente pra ser
uma empreendedora para ter uma startup
para fazer uma empresa de sucesso
e aí é uma das minhas primeiras
surpresas foi quando montei em primeiro
está taco
nós fomos convidados a participar de um
processo de aceleração de empresas no
mundo digital e eu descobri que não
sabia coisa nenhuma eu descobri que
tinha um monte de outras habilidades que
eu teria que adquirir que eu teria que
melhorar para conseguir realmente ter
sucesso eu descobrir que mais do que uma
carreira acadêmica eu precisaria saber
um pouco de tudo eu precisaria saber
entender coisas que eu nunca ia
voluntariamente estudar tipo analytics
tipo desenvolvimento de falar em público
e isso foi uma das coisas que é ao longo
do tempo passaram a ser constantes
eu descobri que o desconhecido faz parte
da vida empreendedora que todo dia você
tem que se reciclar que todo dia você
tem que mudar e se aperfeiçoar um
pouquinho mas eu descobri que eu não
precisava fazer isso sozinha que eu
podia também trazer outras pessoas para
trabalharem junto comigo pra acreditar
em um sonho junto comigo que teriam as
habilidades que eu não fosse ex pet não
precisava ser top em tudo mas que no
mínimo precisaria conversar beber
conversar com ela sem entender o que
elas fazem
e aí vem a uma das coisas que eu tenho
como marca realmente de empreendedorismo
toda a minha carreira acadêmica tudo que
eu escutei foi super importante é super
importante no meu dia a dia mas a minha
capacidade de me adaptar de aceitar de
corrigir de fazer com que aquele erro
que eu cometi vire um aprendizado que de
uma maneira criativa eu consigo achar
uma outra solução pra mim é pra
conseguir colocar o produto no mercado
para conseguir passar a minha ideia é
fundamental
eu descobri que mais do que habilidades
técnicas
eu tinha a maior habilidade que o
empreendedor precisa ter pra conseguir
empreender para conseguir se manter
empreendendo que é a resiliência é a
capacidade de mesmo quando está tudo
perdido como quando têm todas as dúvidas
quando está tudo errado a gente não
surta
a gente começa de novo a gente aprende
um pouco muda e segue em frente
mas dentro da do mundo empreendedor a
especialmente o mercado digital que a
área que o ato
o que acontece muito é a perda de pouco
porque o que a gente quer fazer tudo ao
mesmo tempo é uma empresa normalmente
pequena que você tem que desempenhar
várias funções e no meio dessas funções
você acaba realmente ficando sem saber o
que fazer o seu dia
então eu aprendi que eu só conseguiria
fazer as coisas se conseguisse
estabelecer pequenas metas e me
comprometer atingir focar em parte
daquilo que eu queria até chata e saber
esperar até ficar pronto porque porque
às vezes quando a gente tem uma idéia a
gente pense idéias que elas vão ser
gigantesca que elas vão realmente mudar
o mundo e até chegar nesse ponto tem um
trajecto muito longo e esse trajeto ele
é construído dia-a-dia etapa a etapa
problema há problema e que se eu não
conseguir se focar
eu não conseguiria completar cada etapa
então que não adiantaria ampv querer
fazer tudo e não ter realmente um plano
para conseguir realizar isso mundo
empreendedor hoje é um mundo muito
glamouroso
hoje é mais fácil você ver o
empreendedor na capa de uma revista do
que às vezes um ator de novela é comum
vocês verem alguma reportagem onde tem
cifras milionárias maravilhosas de
rapazes de 20 anos que construíram
alguma ferramenta só que na prática isso
não é assim
o dia de empreendedor ele tem muito
trabalho a mesma pessoa que faz o café
de manhã eu faço café da manhã é a mesma
que aparece na tv à noite
existe uma série de de pequenas ações de
pequenas burocracias de trabalho chato
que têm que ser feitos pra poder aquele
sistema funcionar pra poder aquilo fica
pronto e sair perfeito na mídia então é
importante que independente do que você
veja como referência
você mantém os pés no chão você lembre
quem você é de onde você veio e quais
são os seus valores
por quê que você está ali o que te
motiva todo dia a levantar ea fazer mais
um pouquinho porque é esse dia a dia que
é o maior aprendizado é o maior
benefício se você ficar milionário
ganhar milhões aparecer na capa da
revista famosa isso vai passar
é aquele momento ali mas a sua
trajetória a sua história ela tá junto
das pessoas que convivem com você não
tenha com você pessoas que de vez em
quando quando você tiver um dia
megalomaníaco lembre que você é o cara
que comer coxinha na padaria porque isso
vai te fazer falta e isso vai te trazer
todo teu propósito todo o seu objetivo e
tudo aquilo que realmente é importante
para você
absorver nesse momento é difícil muito
difícil
tem dias que a gente se perde tem dia
que a gente tem notícias ruins
tem dia que aquela nossa ideia a gente
encontra um cara gente conta pra ele
super empolgada e o cara fala pra gente
cara e daí
ou a gente está lá correndo trabalhando
14 e 15 horas por dia chega em casa
cansada e à sua vizinha fala-se na ásia
mas até essa hora desafios vão ter o
tempo todo como obstáculos vão ter o
tempo todo
a diferença do empreendedor é o que ele
faz com isso porque para o empreendedor
obstáculo é motivação eu é aprendizado é
com a possibilidade de fazer melhor
possibilidade de aprender mais rápido eu
aprendi em três anos de empreendedorismo
na prática no dia a dia
com raça com sangue com dificuldade
financeira um pouco funcionário mais do
que eu aprendi em toda minha carreira
acadêmica em toda a minha vida
profissional e hoje não existe em lugar
nenhum no mundo que eu gostaria de está
aí não sei fazendo o que eu faço então
eu realmente tenho uma realização
profissional mas é importante que cada
pessoa saiba aonde quer chegar
o que você quer realmente deixar de
marca como você quer viver os próximos
anos da sua vida quando chegar lá na
frente o que é que você quer deixar
quando eu comecei a aprender eu achava
que o meu objetivo meu propósito era ter
qualidade de vida ter tempo para as
minhas filhas
e aí eu poderia fazer isso de várias
formas diferentes poderia simplesmente
parar de trabalhar e passar o dia
cozinhando para elas mas eu não seria
feliz até porque as minhas habilidades
culinárias são bem dos idosos
e aí eu fui procurar mais um pouco o meu
propósito porque eu estava trabalhando
tanto porque eu tava me envolvendo em
tantas atividades porque eu estava
fazendo tanta coisa e aí eu cheguei à
conclusão de que eu era uma
empreendedora que queria ser milionária
que dinheiro é legal dinheiro móvel
mundo dinheiro permite uma série de
coisas pra gente e que eu ia poder ter
qualidade de vida é poder ficar com as
minhas filhas vai poder viajar
eu ia poder fazer um monte de coisa
fazia sentido e aí eu me imaginei tendo
muito dinheiro e eu percebi que quando
chegasse lá eu ainda assim essa infeliz
e percebi que eu ia chegar lá eu não
está satisfeita com aquilo que eu ia
deixar não se iludam ainda quer ser
milionário
mas aí eu procurei dentro de mim o que
era realmente importante porque eu fazia
tudo isso porque eu queria tudo isso e
aí quem descobriu o meu propósito foi a
pessoa mais sábia do mundo
a minha filha de 3 anos
uma vizinha pouco curiosa vivendo entrar
sair viajar
enfim parou e perguntou pra mim porque
você faz isso
o que é que você faz e eu parei naqueles
microssegundos eternos e fiquei
enrolando com essa pergunta ea minha
filha estava do lado e ela falou pra mim
assim a minha mãe ela ajuda as outras
pessoas a realizar os sonhos dela então
descobrir empreendendo que o que me dar
mais para quem me dá mais prazer é
ajudar as pessoas a realizar o sonho
dela seja criando um produto que melhora
a qualidade de vida dela seja resolvendo
um problema que poderia ser feito
resolvido de uma forma melhor mais
eficiente seja contando a minha história
para que outras pessoas possam ver
possam criar atalhos que possam chegar
mais rápido ao objetivo para realizar o
sonho dela então descobrir que mais
importante do que onde quando eu queria
chegar
era onde eu estaria quando estivesse
realmente realizada e hoje eu sou uma
pessoa dura mas realizada profissional e
emocionalmente
o que eu tenho pra dizer pra vocês é o
seguinte por que eu não sei quantos de
vocês aqui são empreendedores querem ser
empreendedores
mas independente de empresa um
dependente de objetivo
não existe regra não existe caminho não
existe nenhum mapa que funcione para
todo mundo
você pode ser feliz trabalhando numa
empresa corporativa você pode ser feliz
sendo funcionário público você pode ser
feliz com uma barraquinha de
cachorro-quente ou com uma empresa de 1
1 bilhão
quem vai definir o que traz a sua
felicidade e o que te motiva e me faz
seguir adiante é você porque sucesso é
relativo sucesso tem que ser seu
dentro do seu parâmetro e daquilo que
realiza você pode ter uma empresa
milionária pode você pode ser mãe de
trigêmeos pode você pode fazer qualquer
coisa que você quer
desde que você tenha vontade motivação e
um propósito que você entenda que a
dificuldade vai existir problema vai
existir mas que isso faz parte o teu
aprendizado
isso faz parte do teu caminho e que isso
tem que ser pra você ao bom algo
prazeroso algo útil
muitas pessoas vão dizer pra você que
não vai dar certo
muitas pessoas vão dizer pra vocês que
isso que é impossível entrar prefeito me
disseram muitas vezes que eu não podia
ser mãe que não podia ser empreendedora
que não podia ser mulher que não podia
ser tudo isso ao mesmo tempo que eu não
poderia ter mais uma empresa que eu não
conseguiria dar conta
há dois anos atrás era impossível pra
mim subir no palco e falar pra vocês mas
graças à vontade de vencer o desafio
graças a minha motivação e ao meu
propósito
graças a vocês eu vim aqui hoje e fica
obrigada